hey guys how you doing let's all let's
all stand up everyone get up you guys
have been sitting for about an hour and
a half or two hours all right and find
someone you don't know and give them the
best hug you've had in the last couple
days
hey you're not hugging let's get this
alright alright that's enough hugging
you you you guys can find each other on
coffee meets bagel if it was alright so
I'm gonna talk to you guys about our
company how we started how we've messed
up an incredible amount and then kind of
what we're building this is a picture of
me drinking a gin and tonic I don't know
why it's on there but it was a that was
a awesome wedding all right so so raise
your hand if you've ever broken a
smartphone before
alright so that's it's a pretty big
market so we so I'm one of our own best
customers I went to Cal Poly with my
brother chip who presented last year
raise your hand if you're here last year
oh come on all right
well his talk sucked and mines gonna be
way better all right so he's eight so
he's a winemaker but what happened is in
college we got cut off by our parents
and they're like hey you guys need to
figure out a way to make money so we
started a beekeeping operation because
the margins and honey are actually
pretty high and then and then so he
started we started making wine so we
couldn't afford alcohols were like why
don't we make it and and then I've kept
breaking my phone I'm like we're
spending all the money that we're making
from selling wine to kids in the dorms
on fixing our phones so we need to we
need to figure out how to how to make
some more money and and not pay Apple
229 dollars to fix an iPhone 3GS so on
the fifth or sixth time breaking my
phone I ended up ordering the ordering
some parts online and then it took about
four hours to fix I broke the phone more
than it was broken before taking it
apart but at least I didn't have to go
wait in line set up an appointment and
have a painful experience and then my
roommate was like hey can you fix my
phone it broke I'm like yeah I'll order
another $15 part and then fix it I
didn't charge him but I should have and
so I was like this is a really cool
business but I don't have any customers
I'm just fixing my buddy's phones that
go to parties
and and so I ended up going to a career
fair and I was walking around and I paid
$20 to buy ten sheets of paper to print
my resume on that read like it was like
highschool education there's like
nothing I've done I worked at a couple
fish stores that was really fun and and
actually I worked at fish stores because
I've always kept saltwater fish tanks
and corals were really expensive and I
got an employee discount and I worked
for $5 an hour and I got corals for next
to nothing so that was cool but actually
the story gets better so so I'm walking
around and I'm and I remember looking at
a Clorox Clorox booth there at a career
fair at Cal Poly and I remember thinking
like I'm gonna spend a summer working on
like marketing or social media for
Clorox it's probably not the best use of
my time and I end up bumping into one of
my friends who actually just started a
company that went through YC which is
awesome but I bump into a guy and he's
like hey you're the guy who fixes
iPhones I'm like yeah what's going on
he's like can you fix I broke my phone
yesterday can you fix it and so I was
like yeah actually I have I have parts
in my golf cart because I had a golf
cart in college and I drove it to and
from class we're we're so there's
another story about how we acquired the
golf cart which find me after and I'll
tell you it we painted it so you can
never guess that it was someone else's
golf cart so I end up I was like yeah I
can fix your phone and I ended up
throwing out all my resumes before I'd
hand it out any one of them went and
fixed his phone and then I was like hey
this could be a cool business so I'm
gonna need to figure out how to how to
make more customers so I actually
skipped class and I went to the library
and got on Microsoft Paint for those
that remember it and made the most
terrible looking flyer you've ever seen
that's like broke and I found and I made
it in neon colors and then the cool
thing about Cal Poly I hope they never
watch this but they subsidize color
printing at five cents each is very
cheap and so I printed two or three
hundred flyers and then handed them to
my friends and my roommates and I was
like when you're going to class hang
these up and on the first day I got a
phone call being like hey can you this
is actually there's a funny story behind
this so I dated two girls named Courtney
and it's good so I dated two girls not
at the same time but but so I dated two
girls named Courtney and the first
person that called me was like hey I
broke my phone I saw your flyer can you
fix it I'm like yeah absolutely what
type she's like I have a iPhone 3GS and
I'm like all right that's awesome what's
what's your name and she's like my
name's Courtney and I'm like this is a
sign this is this is awesome and so I
gave her my address and I said hey yeah
bring it over I'll fix it later and she
walks in and she's like hey I think I've
been to your house before I'm like I
don't think you have and and she's like
no Mike lives here I'm like yeah Mike's
my roommate she's like oh my brother's
best friends with Mike his name's
Anthony and I was like Anthony Martin
she's like yeah I was like oh yeah I'm
good buddies with him and that actually
became my co-founder is let's give a
round of applause for Anthony and his
sister
so so that was our first my first
customer was my co-founder sister which
was which was crazy and so I ended up
hanging the coolest thing about flyers
as you can hang them anywhere and
there's and if you staple them high
enough in the room the janitorial staff
or the teachers can't tear them down so
we'd go
we'd like going at night or after 6:00
p.m. and then like staple fliers up
towards the clock where it was like 10
12 feet high and they never get torn
down but every time when you're in class
you'd look at it and you'd be like oh my
gosh I have two hours left and there's
an annoying neon flier next to the clock
that's telling me to fix my iPhone and
and so we ended up graduating and was
thinking about dropping out I still
don't know if that was a good idea or a
bad idea I think the jury's still out on
that but ended up like the more
customers I would meet and service the
less important education and school got
and and I was like well I'm a psychology
major I can probably I can probably get
by with graduating so ended up
graduating and the and I was talking to
my dad and I'm like hey what are you
he's like what are you doing after
graduation I'm and I'm like I don't I
don't really have a plan I like I think
I cracked he's going pretty well and he
was like well why don't you do that
full-time and I remember thinking that
it it never it always been just like a
really cool college job had never been
something bigger than that and I think
one of the coolest things a parent can
give to their children is permission to
explore adventure and like go out on
their own and so and like something
switched in my mind I'm like oh my gosh
I just got permission to essentially max
out my credit cards and start an iPhone
repair company which sounded crazy at
the time and so Anthony ended up calling
me and he's like hey what are you doing
for what are you doing for money and I'm
like you need to fix phones and he's
like alright cool he was running a
textbook rental and exchange company and
and so I just sent him the Flyers we
changed his phone number on it and I
sent him like a YouTube video on how to
fix iPhones and there's actually still a
flier somewhere on Santa Barbara's
campus that he gets a call like every
two weeks and someone's like hey do you
fix phones he's like where is that flier
and they're like oh it's in the poly SCI
building and they're like tear it down
they're like it's way too high and and
so so that he's it became like the
absolute coolest coolest job I could
imagine and after graduation were like
well we need well I'll do I'll go back
to a chip story we can integrate those
credit lot he's my winemaking brother so
he calls me he's like hey what are you
doing for money I'm like you need to fix
phones he's like all right yeah I'll
just print it on my business card that
is it cool if I say I'm an executive
yeah of course we have three people in
the company you can be an executive so
he he prints like business cards that
say like wine maker and I cracked
executive on it and and I sent him up
some screens and he goes to a party and
he's trying to impress a cute girl and
and he hits her phone out of her hand to
break it because he's like I can fix
this and so so he hits he hits the phone
out and and she's like you're an
it's a 3GS and he's like I don't have 3G
parts if you remember there's two
hypotheses so he calls me in a panic I'm
like oh yeah there you we definitely
don't have parts for those and he ended
up having to buy her new fan which was
odd and so so that's so it started but
it was like what worked on one campus
started working on another campus
started working in San Francisco and and
what it started as I put on demand
iPhone repair I think what we'll get to
is it's actually not about repair at all
it's not even about iPhones it's about
building a network that you press a
button anywhere you are around the world
and someone comes and solves your
technology needs but it started as on a
man phone repair and the cool thing is
is we believe that your iPhone is
actually the remote control to your life
and if you can insert a brand and a
service in between you and that phone
what you can get into other verticals
because you've already gained consumer
trust and and you've already solved
their deepest need which is connection
connection to the world and so what we
decided is like how do we create the
Triple A for your devices and and the
cool thing is is we think that repair is
a Trojan horse into our consumers lives
and it's it's going crazy
they have like 20 slides and I'm on
slide 2 so this is gonna be good
here's a picture that I don't know why
it's on there we can go to the next one
cool so how it started as my own
customer I still am i fixed my iphone 6
for the fourth time this year
yesterday actually and i don't like it
because the six parts are actually
expensive so it costs us a lot of money
to fix it but whatever so where we are
now so we're at about 115 employees we
have six offices which is insane because
at graduation day we packed my
co-founders truck and we're like hey
let's go up to San Francisco there's no
way we can build a massive company in
San Luis Obispo and ended up driving up
and crashing on my brother's couch
another chip story so he winemakers are
the best so he I'm working with Anthony
and we're at our computers and it's like
9:40 a.m. on a Tuesday and chip like
comes out and we've been living on his
couch for two months and he's like
stretching probably hungover and he's
like ah how much do you guys work like
chip-ins 9:40 in the morning you need to
get up and but so what we you're like
hey it's our time to leave so we ended
up Craig's listing a place in Sunnyvale
and moving into a basement in Sunnyvale
and then ended up hiring a graphic
designer
her name's Leslie she saw my mspaint
fliers and she's like these are terrible
can I make you better ones to have to
look at them all day in class and I like
this is annoying I'm like oh my gosh
absolutely and then I paid people in two
dollar bills that's a life hack paid
people in two dollar bills
people love two dollar bills
and so the whole idea is like how do you
how do you how do you scale what was
working in these three cities how do we
do that how do we do that around the US
and then we came up with this model that
we call the itec model where we have
well just some numbers so in the last 30
days we've had about 10,000 people apply
to be an AI tech we say no to 97 to 98%
of them either based on like where they
are skill do they fit our model are they
going to treat our customers better than
any any person than the other 98% and so
we take the top 2% of people that apply
to be an AI tech and we try to equip
them with all the tools they need to be
successful so this is supply chain
marketing material training back-end
support regional management but most
importantly of Brandin customers and so
we built a we built a a dispatch
platform where anywhere you are around
the US you can put in the problem you're
having and it goes to your local AI tech
they can claim it then they'll meet you
at wherever's community for you so
they're all mobile and and Starbucks is
actually a huge place that I text love
to service customers because a lot of
people don't understand that you can you
can I can drop my phone right now break
it and in the next 20 minutes have
someone here and replace it good as new
and so we've we have we just passed
2,300 ITEX in the company and and they
are just the most incredible service
professionals you've ever met you're our
average high tech is between 30 to 40
years old he or she has a family they're
not what we thought college students
would be the way to expand it's not
college students and we're planning on
adding about 5,000 more people to the
company this year which is insane
because five years ago we were living in
a basement trying to fix phones so it
started by word of mouth came a cool
college job don't know why that pictures
there so becoming bigger like how do you
scale something bigger than just
something that's out of a dorm room and
that's that's been the that's been the
question we're trying to answer because
it one of my biggest
years we won't build a big enough
company that makes an impact on how
massive this market is so in 2009 about
5% of the world's population had
smartphones at the end of this year it
should be about 42% apple sold 74
million iPhones last quarter it's about
34,000 iPhones every hour 24 hours a day
we we know that this market is
absolutely huge well what else can you
do besides repair and that is you can
you can buy back old devices you can
deliver new devices and then the Golden
Goose is actually a membership plan
where for $7 month any time you break
your device whether it's an Android iPad
whatever you press the button and we fix
it for $25 on the spot which is insane
so become a master of your own domain a
lot of people ask us hey why didn't you
why don't you fix this we have someone
who joined our company that the first
call they got was someone trying to fix
their TomTom GPS unit and he's like why
don't we fix tom-toms and it's like well
we actually think we can be the best in
the world that iOS and Android repair
and then we can move into other
verticals and it's been an insane uphill
battle so the one of the things I'll
give you a fish analogy because you guys
know that I worked in a fish store so
when expanding cast a really big net and
throw back what you don't want we
believe this for all the tests we do
internally it's hey let's see what works
and then let's get rid of stuff that
doesn't work and then let's keep what
does but let's keep everything on the
table as a possibility until it's not a
possibility and that's been that's been
crazy
I put slow growth on here because
growing fast is actually not always the
best thing so we we were we try to grow
it about 10 to 15 percent
month-over-month which by certain
standards is either really fast or
really slow but it took us three years
to get to a point where we're actually
comfortable growing at 15% a month so
don't great businesses take time don't
expect to come out with an app or a
website or a platform and have like
crazy adoption unless you're meerkat or
pears
which was sweet in South by Southwest
you guys all need to go next year one of
the one of the things that we also live
by is shoot bullets not cannonball or
shoot bullets than cannonballs in that
you want to you don't want to spend too
much resources on something that doesn't
work so if you're gonna change your
entire website layout and then you
launch your website and it doesn't work
well you just spent six months pushing
something that that actually has less
KPIs well you could have just hacked
something together move fast
I'm not a engineer my co-founders not an
engineer
hug your engineers if you have one or
you have a technical co-founder there
they make the world a better place and
are absolutely amazing can we get a
round of applause for I think all
engineers just in general because
because we are we are all if we're at
this conference chances are we are not
engineers so I put a be testing is your
best friend for life so test everything
analytics you get better at your job by
analytics and and knowing what dozen
doesn't work there's a lot of really
cool a be testing platforms were like my
new changes so we check there's a button
on our site that is the button that is
the difference between requesting and I
tech and not requesting an I tech and we
changed it from request attack to get
quote and it increased conversions by
three and a half percent that's insane
and so test everything and if it doesn't
work then it's it took a couple hours to
make it work how do we scale this is
just a be testing so we run about twenty
five web tests a month which what I
think's really interesting is right now
the we get a couple million people to
our website a quarter but right now half
of them don't know that they're getting
a completely different homepage than the
other half and that's that's insane
because they're going to have a good
experience but they don't know that
we're actually running a control on a
new web page right now so and then
always think bigger one of my favorite
things is when I'm when I'm talking to
people whether it's investors or
other entrepreneurs and other CEOs one
of my favorite things is when they
actually have a bigger vision for a
branch of our company than I do myself
and it gives me the chills to think
about when someone says what last week
someone goes oh you're you're building
the last the world's last technical
workforce and I've never thought of it
like that and we're gonna add probably
20,000 people as I text to our company
in the next next 18 months and it
literally could be building the world's
last technical workforce and that I love
the thought of people thinking bigger
than yourself I think founders generally
they get so in the they get so in the
weeds and they they're looking at such a
micro level they they can forget the
macro level I think Walker a teespring
earlier he's a he's absolutely great guy
but it it seems it's crazy too if you
think about well what happens if you can
actually put a t-shirt on 5% 10% 20% of
the world's population it's it's it's
massive and it seems silly if you don't
go back and and just think big always
about what you're doing and then make
decisions that you would make when
you're larger one of the so one of the
things that I do personally is is I
think five years from now if I'm looking
back at this decision what I have made
the same decision and that's every day I
try to get better at my job I hope
everyone on our team tries to do that as
well I want to go to sleep and when I
wake up I want to be a better founder
than I was when I went to bed the night
before and I always try to look back and
look back at my decisions and like what
I have made that decision now whether
it's hiring your best friend which the
jury's still out on it I've
unfortunately had to let some of my best
friends go that that didn't work out but
it's still I needed to go through that
growth curve to learn that maybe it's
not the best idea to how your best
friend but when it does work it is your
the best idea so decisions are make
decisions that you would make when
you're a billion dollar company that you
would when you're a three person
start-up in a basement in Sunnyvale so
this is a cool this is a cool map so
every blue pin is
someone that requested and i-tech in the
last 60 days in places we don't have
ITEX yet the purple pins are current
locations of ITEX that kind of get
covered up and then the left is
quarter-over-quarter i tech growth so
we're gonna add 5,000 night x this year
this is a cool thing so one of the
things that we live by is how do we make
our customers and our users champions
our ITEX will do probably about thirty
million dollars in just repair trade and
and and protection plans of the twenty
five dollars they show up they fix your
device that's insane I love that we're
building a network that we can take care
of our customers and then everyone wins
this is this is actually a fun one so
one of the things people always ask us
is like hey have you guys thought of
doing this and I'm like I don't want to
spend time and resources validating a
completely new vertical I'd actually
rather have a big slow corporation spend
50 million dollars on something that
does or doesn't work and then I want to
study them so closely so I want to talk
to current employees I want to talk to
former employees I want to talk to the
media and press that like release
stories on it I really think that you
one of the hack is that you let other
people spend their money and then you
see what works if it validates then
freaking charge a head on it and if it
doesn't work then you're like maybe I
should do something different hire for
strength not lack of weakness
that's a shout out to mr. Ben Horowitz
and one of his blog posts and that took
a long time to that look took a long
time to learn because when you're
interviewing people for your team and
for your company your culture you're
like oh my gosh they're so amazing at
this yeah well they suck at this and
it's like well what is their role and if
they're amazing at what they're actually
doing well you can actually make
trade-offs for that person and so don't
think that you want like an all-around
excellent person I'd hire four people on
specific domains and verticals and then
make them champions in that out-innovate
the things that kill you so a lot of a
lot of times it's like what are you
gonna do when sapphire glass comes out
we will probably fix our glass because
it breaks but yes it does you guys see
that call-out right there
so just out innovate things that is
gonna that is going to put you out of
business what keeps me up at night is
like what can what can kill us as a
company tomorrow and then how can we
actually beat it and whether it's having
a a contingency plan to pivot or a
actually we're gonna blow out this
vertical if this vertical gets shut off
and then you also don't necessarily need
to know what you want to be when you
start out you'll kind of involve evolve
into that this is the future that's a
really good picture of our team we have
these smart cars raise your hand if
you've ever seen a smart car in SF a
little I cracked car I mean we need more
of them so we have a couple hundred
around the u.s. right now they're
cruising around so the future is not
actually about fixing a broken Android
tablet the future is about what can you
do when you're in your customers home
and and we think that there's going to
be a day where we well we actually think
that as new technology comes on the
market your life actually gets more
inherently complex so your your nest
thermostat it takes up mental bandwidth
when what you had was a mercury tube
that just completed a circuit when
temperatures changed it makes your life
easier but it actually adds like mental
complexity your Apple watch that came
out today is actually more make sure I
have more complex than your previous
watch or if you didn't have one your
feature phone was actually easier to use
than your iPhone and so our thing is is
how do you how does our network actually
take away and remove all that complexity
and if you can put someone in every city
worldwide that that needs to press a
button and solve their I'm going to turn
off the little timer will just talk to
another 30 minutes so we want to build
the network that solves all of our
customers problems at the click of a
button so that you come home and and
you're like oh my gosh my router doesn't
work or my nest thermostats off or my
drop cam I don't know how to said
you literally click your itec button or
your I cracked button and we show up and
solve your problems for you on the spot
that's going to be very exciting email
me directly
AJ dot-com I get enough spam so now my
emails out there for everyone and then
also if you're one of one of our
favorite types of people to hire like my
favorite type of person joint add up to
our team our former founders and former
CEOs and people who have started stuff
and and have ambition I look at if
someone says hey I'd love to come work
for you guys for for a year and then I
want to start my own thing it's like oh
my gosh come in like learn as much as
you can add value and and and hopefully
you'll leave a better person every every
job that you have you should leave that
job a better person or like more skilled
than before always trying to make upward
movements and then I have email me if
you're with here with your boss I will
go into QA I'm pretty honest with
questions so if you guys want to ask
tough questions or weird questions I can
probably answer them my man
for sure yeah absolutely so the question
is how do you maintain quality as you
grow add at individuals to your company
that's a great question I think as we've
gotten as we're actually growing we're
getting more applicants so the
percentage that we're accepting is
decreasing but what it what it comes
down to is when you're looking at
on-demand economy companies you're
looking at our goal is we want our i
text to make thirty to fifty dollars an
hour and and we look at there's actually
three tiers of on-demand economy so
there's your your uber your instacart
your your ship your post mates they're
at a they're at like kind of your entry
level
$10.99 economy and then you have your
what we call the semi-pro economy which
we think we fall into we're not anyone
you can't click a button on handy and
have someone come fix your device or
install your nest thermostat and so
we're trying to build this semi-pro
economy that that you'd be surprised at
how I mean fifty six percent of our high
Tech's have college degrees the last
census twenty I think twenty eight
percent of the US population did so we
have this like incredible incredible
technical workforce that is not your
regular contractors and then we layered
it once more we're actually they're not
our contractors we sell them parts and
then they take money from their
customers and so so we we don't deal
with I guess contractor issues because
we're essentially a lead supplier and a
part supplier it's up over time so if
you want to find AJ told you all
questions so thank you for your talk
yeah we're just gonna we have to move on
to the next but think about all right
thank you guys